من جهته قال رئيس المجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان قال انه لا يسعى للانقلاب
او تغيير الوضع في البلاد وانه لن يتراجع
عن الاتفاق الاطاري
لغايه ما نكملوا
فيهم
قضايا تناقش حاجات الدوله لكن هن هذه
القضايا اتفقنا عليه قوه معينه الا مع بعض
هو كل القوه ما فيها زول ما عدا المؤتمر
الوطني والله الناس كانوا ثاني
عشان كده قلنا نجروا
الوطني ولا قلنا مع الناس السودانيين اللي
ما عندهم ما عنده الجهه ما عنده جهه هم
البلد
طاهر المرضي هل من تفاعل الطاهر وردود
الفعل حول ما قاله شمس الدين الكباشي وعبد
الفتاح البرهان رئيس المجلس السياده
نعم هنالك تفاعل من القوه السياسيه ولكن
ليس رسميا لان بعض القوه السياسيه ترى ان
هذه شروط المكون العسكري او الشروط القوات
المسلحه للمضيق قدما في الاتفاق الايطالي
خاصه هو ان مساله توسيع قاعده المشاركه
هذه واحده من الاسباب التي تحدث عنها
البرهان عندما استولى على السلطه في 25 من
اكتوبر من العام الماضي وقال انه لا بد من
توسيع قائمه المشاركه اذا هذا الحديث الذي
يتحدث عنه البرهان او سدين كباشي هو تاكيد
على المضيق قدما في الاتفاق الايطالي
بالشرق ان تكون هنالك قاعده اوسع للمشاركه
في الحكم خاصه وان شمس الدين كباشي قال ان
هذه القوه التي وقعت على الاتفاق الايطالي
سواء كان من المدنيين او العسكريين ليست
كافيه لتحقيق تحول ديمقراطي او تكوين
حكومه او حتى استقرار سياسي في البلاد
وبالتالي نحن الان لربما نشهد اراء واضحه
وساطعه ومتوقع ايضا من قوه الحريه
المركزي ان تصدر ايضا رايي في هذا الخصوص
من ناحيه رسميه هذا ما اريد ان اسال عنه
يعني هناك هل اوضح مجلس السياده السوداني
ان التعبئه ان هناك تعديلات ربما قد يتم
ادخالها على الاتفاق الاطار السياسي حتى
يعني يتم وصول التوافق جميع القوه التي
امتنعت عن المشاركه والتوقيه
هو ليس التعديلات بالمعنى على ما احتواه
الاتفاق الايطالي ولكن الدعوه للذين لم
يضموا هذا الاتفاق الايطالي يقول بشكل
واضح على القوه السياسيه الموقعه لاتفاق
الايطالي ان توسع صدرها وان تقبل الاخر
حتى يستطيع الانضمام الى هذه الى الاتفاق
الايطالي وفقا لاي نوع من التعديلات
والتوافق على صيغه تمكن من تكوين حكومه
ذات قاعده عريضه تستطيع ان تحقق استقرار
في البلاد لان هنالك خلافات كبيره المجلس
المركزي وهو الجهه الاكبر الموقعه للاتفاق
على الايطالي ترى ان الجهه الاطراف
العمليه السياسيه محدده هي ان يكون خارج
هذه المعادله الوطني والذين كانوا مع
المؤتمر الوطني حتى سقوطه هم يرون ان الان
العمليه السياسيه خارجيه فقط حركه تحرير
السودان بقياده مني اركم انه وحركه العدل
المسلحه لا يمكن ان تحمي الدستور لا يحقق
اجماع وطني ولا يحقق استقرار للبلاد شكرا
لك الطاهر المرضى الجزيره من الخرطوم شكرا
لك